[Musique]
bonjour à toutes et à tous l'invité de
sao cali ce matin robert ça et bonjour
bonjour à tous et à toutes
chaque mission vous êtes membre du cncp
vous allez tenir dimanche votre 16e
assemblée générale c'est l'occasion de
faire le bilan et de parler des
élections municipales entre autres quel
regard jetez vous sur ces élections
d'abord garde personnelle je me souviens
que les premiers aux conférences où
j'allais applaudir et b6 et j'avais 15
ans maternité le fief du vpm depuis je
n'ai jamais laissé le champ politique
donc j'ai vu j'ai entendu et j'y arrive
à la même conclusion que toute la
population à chaque fois que les
échéances et après approche on a des
dizaines et des dizaines de bonnes âmes
qui vienne sauver la commune et régler
les problèmes des peuples bon voir le
résultat
on a toujours la même rhétorique dipity
pas de pitié et disons roi monté
remonter parce qu'on a toujours la même
rhétorique nos jeunes s'en vont les
vieux souffre et la commune est endettée
à une mauvaise gestion
il ya des trous dans le chemin de monaco
mais aucun de ces eaux là ne dise dans
la campagne
voilà les cause de ces problèmes là
voilà ce que j'avais fait et voilà
comment je vais financer mon programme
radio fm une autre dit j'avais attiré
des capitaux sans ne rien dire puisque
ce sont des gens qui sont supposés avoir
les buts germain docteur comparer
connaître les chiffres dit que je
pourrais faire ça les hommes politiques
aujourd'hui ne sont pas dignes de
confiance
nada sincère et je suis content ce
qu'ils disent tous pourris etc
il y en a deux c'est serena qui essaient
de sauver les meubles mais la plupart
n'essaie pas de placer leur accès
électorale dans le cadre d'une stratégie
globale pour changer la société il m
cible de résoudre aucun problème
martiniquais de changer cette société là
en allant seulement aux élections et on
ne voit ces jours-là travail est nulle
part pendant toute la période des cinq
ans précédents il y en a qui font des
actions sociales pour avoir de la
puanteur
ils vont sur la liste et puis c'est fini
mais quand même
même si les hommes politiques sont
décriés la mobilisation reste forte
d'accord c'est vrai que l'abstention
gagne du terrain
mais quand on voit l'ensemble des
élections les municipales c'est là où il
ya le pense deux participations oui
parce que tristement comme de tous les
pays du monde les gens qui sont pauvres
les gens qui sont en difficulté
s'approche de l'autorité dans l'espoir
d'avoir un travail pour les enfants une
amélioration parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
explications politique et théorique
justement qui leur permettrait de voir
que c'est le nook achats ayant panier
puis à félix hautala il y a des élus
correct il y en a qui essaient et jamy
ont beaucoup de conseillers municipaux
dont on ne parle pas on parle souvent du
meilleur qui bénévolement font beaucoup
de choses et avec des associations
mais tout ça c'est chayer de blond
premier encore une fois parce qu'il n'a
pas ils n'ont peine stratégie tenant
compte du fait que nous sommes une
colonie que nous n'avons pas de pouvoir
que l'état se désengage que sens unique
c'est populaire
on ne pourra pas avancer en continuant à
décalré s'est excusé le mot à détruire
l'adversaire pour pouvoir gagner des
élections on entretient la division dans
le peuple ont refusé de cautionner des
choses positives
condé lui fait parce qu'on n'est pas
d'or j'ai déjà les ordres du même bord
je gère j'ai déjà dit ça plusieurs fois
mais c'est mon modèle
paul wernick était de droite j'étais
avec lui au conseil régional
il vient me dit ça y est mon cabas aux
procurations mois qu'a duré la fête du
piment audible par tous qui l'aï dit mon
nom mais savions qu'ils voudront pas
précisément savourer voté pou sak i bon
c'est ça qu'on arrivera à voir dans
l'électorat dressait quand même table
mortifère j'ai envie de dire ça ça fait
peur c'est aussi de là
as politique électoraliste mais dans
notre population il y a énormément de
gens positifs qui travaillent qui ont
des initiatives économiques qui anime
bénévolement 10 des associations
culturelles et sportives qui prennent le
véhicule pour mener des jeunes filles du
foot la majorité de nos peuples fait des
choses positives mais justement le fait
qu' une petite caste d'élus entretient
la division pour empêcher que ce
mouvement-là ne prenne le pouvoir
populaire
ben c'est ça qu'il faut résoudre comme
pro question est ce que vous allez
soutenir des candidats ce qui a
déclenché des candidats qui ont grâce à
vos yeux
non d'abord par principe nous allons
soutenir les candidats qui seraient
présentés par notre allié fidèle que le
mode et basse parce que nous savons qu'à
entre les périodes électorales
cette organisation travaille sur le
terrain pour les choses fondamentales
préparation écologie etc
alors je prends principal et non pas
pour désigner donc comme un pirana here
je vais pas apprécié que nous allons
soutenir les candidats du modemas c est
les candidats du modemas par exemple le
maire du prêcheur fait partie des
personnes que vous elle pouvait soutenir
je peux soutenir mon organisation
soutient tous les candidats qui seraient
présentées par une association une
organisation qui fait un travail
brillant dans le pays c'est tout
d'accord pas de nom pas de candidat
spécifique
je vous ai parlé d'une lumière du
prêcheur c'est vous et allez c'est
quelqu'un qui fait du bon travail dans
sa commune il n'y a aucun problème pour
le roi connaître et pour dire que ce
travail là méritent d'être soutenus
maintenant le cncp ne va pas s'engager
dans la campagne électorale à faire des
meetings excité dans le rôle de soutien
mais là nous allons plutôt consacrer
cette période intensifier le travail
idéologique théorique politique pour
dire aux gens pas tomber adam divisions
inutiles et pas suivre mon tabouret pour
déminer pilet iv oblivion
celui qui dans tous les partis
politiques sans exception il y a des
gens de valeur des gens honnêtes d'un
pouce et puis il ya aussi des bandits
des voyous des gens incessant de même à
droite à doit à gauche je ne cite qu'un
exemple sans nommer comme un maire de
droite responsable aux partis politiques
de droite appellent les responsables
indépendants disent que je suis pour
dire j'ai vu que tu faisais une école de
parents très été détourné jeudi après
veux tu venir piloter un travail comme
ça dans ma commune je travaille deux ans
avec sur ce projet-là bon donc pour moi
c'est ce que la personne fait qui compte
le candidat celui qui a besoin de
détruire que l'équipe d'en face
non tout le travail culturel qu'est fait
l'annoncé du pipeau je ne parle pas mais
regardez il ya un décès mob qui a acquis
s'est emporté dans une conférence sur ce
sont des voyous se désole de tous les
partis il ya des hommes car des boutons
et nous tous en tant qu'individu nous
sommes certainement en colère nous
disons des choses car être dépassé par
le cas dépasser ça ne pas passer ça ne
veut pas dire que nous sommes des voyous
alors ce que aussi ncp parce qu'il y en
a deux atouts qui non non non non non il
ya deux personnes il ya deux groupes qui
seront votées ces liens il ya un an au
chat virtuel agité par grand semblait
qui n'est pas la sienne gp tout personne
sérieuse qui a fait une enquête c'est
comme ça n'existe pas pour des gros
rideau est ce que vous êtes dans le
droit fil de ma question est ce que la
réconciliation est possible
réconciliation entre des gens qui
veulent travailler pour le pays qui se
bat pour la souveraineté
et puis quelques personnes qui ont trahi
l'organisation pour avoir un poste je
pense l'auteur est impossible qu'on
pouvait faire si des différences
différences pourquoi des gens qui
veulent servir leur pays vont
disparaître mais j'avais faire une
alliance avec marc on ne sait pas ce que
je dis je mens dessous
c'est bien je peux vous parlent de ce
qu'ils sont qui se revendique également
du cncp et qui sont alliés aux grands
ensembles et est ce que ce groupe là
c'est possible cette alliance c'est ce
groupe
ce que je veux dire c'est que quel que
soit le martiniquais lamartine caisse ou
est il commis toutes les erreurs du
monde qui disent abf
on s'était trompé en a fait un bond mais
mettons nous d'accord faisons des choses
sérieuses ensemble ça ne me pose aucun
problème j'ai pas de haine personnelle
j'ai pas de france
ce que je veux c'est des gens qui soient
sincères qu'ils soient honnêtes il ne
faut pas sincères et alors là non mais
c'est vous que non alors oui le problème
c'est que faire quand nous consacrons
beaucoup de temps à parler de ça nous
alimentons les divisions un conte
j'attends de vous une grippe en clair la
réponse claire je ne travaille qu'avec
des gens sincères pour laisser ne sont
pas c'est clair c'est net
bon alors on tourne la page puisqu'il ya
des choses plus importantes qui
concernent les parts d'une icône au b
pau il nous reste que deux minutes alors
le titre générique de cette assemblée
générale du 2 dimanche
c'est avançons ensemble pour mieux vivre
et vous dites qu'il faut surmonter les
divisions artificielles et je vous cite
et les barrières érigées par les ennemis
de l'humanité pour construire l'autre
monde
l'autre monde possible c'est qu'ils les
balles et les ennemis de l'humanité
qu'il ya d'abord toute cette
civilisation occidentale protti par les
impérialistes classes riches qui
viennent d'où le noir et c'est inférieur
la femme est inférieur et le cette
mission n'est pas notre frère et c'est
donc tout ce qui divise les populations
entre elles sont nos ennemis
tous ceux qui disent travailler et puis
je prends le profit ce sont nos ennemis
en tout les autres donc les travailleurs
les paysans les ouvriers les jeunes les
personnes âgées qui veulent vivre de
leur travail sainement
ils sont des nôtres pour laisser sont
divisés pourquoi parce que on a détruit
chaînon l'estiment de soi parce qu'on a
cultivé l'auto dénigrement systématique
on ne voit pas ce qui est beau chez nous
on va passer devant v personnes qui
travaillent qui font qu'ils produisent
ça ne nous intéresse pas et puis on voit
un bonhomme à syrte que nous y faire
assez nette de la barre veille
il nous faut nous décoloniser l'esprit
même et c'est pas la faute des gens
c'est le fruit de la pop a band
éducation mal fait et c'est donc
éliminant les divisions ou retrouvant
l'estiment de nous mêmes arrêtons
l'autodénigrement apprenons à résoudre
les contradictions pacifiquement aux
insultes en écoutant l'autre et puis
apprenons à faire l'alliance eu
seulement à partir de ce qui se fait pas
partie de ce qui se dit mais à partir de
ce qui se fait alors je rappelle votre
assemblée générale elle aura lieu le
dimanche
dimanche 8 mai au 26 novembre un nouvel
album
précisons que l'assemblée générale a
déjà été fait bon et qu'il s'agit de
restituer les trois populations et nous
aidons les gens de tous les mouvements
sans exclusive
y compris n'hésite en a qui auraient
envie de réfléchir et de s'amender
robert ça et je vous remercie c'était
son crédit bonne journée à l'écouté de
nos programmes
[Musique]